IDO GREEN: So hello, and welcome
to another episode of
GDL-IL, Google Developers
Live Israel.
Today, I'm quite happy and
very pleased to have my
colleague with me, Sam
Dutton from London.
SAM DUTTON: Thank you so much.
Thanks for inviting me.
It's my first time
at an Israel GDL,
so great to be here.
IDO GREEN: No, thank you, and
hopefully in the near future,
we'll be able to do it
face to face here in
campus Tel Aviv, right?
SAM DUTTON: Fantastic.
Looking forward.
IDO GREEN: Excellent.
So today, we're going to cover
some of the new, cool things
that we have in WebRTC.
Maybe the best thing
would be if I could
just share the slides.
We'll have the links for the
slides and all the other good
stuff that we're going to share
with you later on in the
footnotes of the GDL page on
Google Developer Live, and of
course, I'll have it on my blog,
and Sam definitely will
have it on his blog and on his
G+ page, and you have the
links to both of them
in the event itself.
So feel free to go there.
So today, we're going to speak
about WebRTC, and Sam will be
able to share with us some of
the new, cool demos that are
just showing the power
of this cool API.
Maybe the best thing would be
if, Sam, you could take over
and just go through these slides
and some of the great
links that we have here.
SAM DUTTON: Absolutely.
So we've got this new set of
technologies called WebRTC,
and what that gives us is
real-time communication built
into the browser.
So this is for obvious
applications.
We can think of things like
video chat, exchange of data,
low latency between games,
stuff like file
sharing, even telephony.
Now, the point about WebRTC
where it's been implemented is
that it's peer to peer.
So the communication is
happening between the
browsers, between what's
called peers.
So if we think of technologies
like web sockets, which are
really, really fast, but
they're going via an
intermediary server, and
with WebRTC, it's
directly between the peers.
WebRTC has been built as a free
and open-source project,
doesn't need any plug-ins, and
like I say, it's standardized
and it's free.
It's free for developers to use,
and all the technologies
are free for the end
users as well.
If we start, I guess, with the
most important API in this,
we've got something called
getUserMedia, also known as
media stream.
Now, the WebRTC APIs have been
implemented now in Chrome, on
desktop, and on Android, and
in Firefox, and we're told
coming to Opera on mobile
and on desktop.
So that's great news.
This simpl.info/gUM, and you can
see there that it's asking
me permission box up at the top
there if I can let it use
the camera.
So here we are.
We're using the camera and
we're getting [INAUDIBLE]
a video element.
You can see the code is
pretty simple there.
What's that?
20 lines of code to cover
cross-browser as well.
The stream variable there, that
shows what the stream is
coming from the video, and you
can see [INAUDIBLE] elements,
and then [INAUDIBLE]
the video tracks for that.
[INAUDIBLE] that we have
one video track.
This represents the stuff
coming from the camera.
And you can see there the name
and the label, and so on.
So a really useful API on its
own, kind of fun, but people
are doing cool things
with this.
And when these APIs come up
against each other, we see
these amazing things.
So I love this ASCII
camera example.
What's happening here, it's
actually really simple code.
What we're doing is we're
getting the video stream from
the camera, and we're putting
that onto a canvas element,
pretty straightforward, and
then analyzing each of the
pixels of the canvas element and
turning that into ASCII.
Really, if you look at the
code there, it's pretty
minimal stuff.
So again, this richness where
we're getting one API
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can have a look at
Webcam Toy, which does the
same using Web-GL, and
AudoRecorder here.
What we're doing is we're using
getUserMedia as the
input to web audio.
You allow that, you can see I'm
getting some visualization
there happening with the
canvas element again.
And I can actually download
this content using
what we call a JS.
And if I open up that file, you
can see it there in VLC,
and I can play that
back just there.
So again, one API coming up
against another in really
interesting ways.
Speaking of this, actually,
you might be interested to
check out MediaRecorder.
I've linked to the API there.
This has been implemented in
Firefox Nightly, and it's
coming soon.
We've got an intent
to implement in
Chrome, which is great.
So that's going to be the
ability to record audio and
video files.
And again, some links to
some API stuff there.
Now, to do something more
powerful, the core of WebRTC,
we've got this API,
RTCPeerConnection, and this is
the API for peer to peer
communication.
So the obvious stuff for this
is the ability to do stuff
like video chat, but it also
gets used by the API called
RTCDataChannel.
[INAUDIBLE]
swap these over.
We'll fix these up anyway.
So what this allows
us to do is video
chat between browsers.
We've got a link to an
application there.
What I'd really recommend if
you want to get your head
around RTCPeerConnection is to
have a go at the Codelab there
on Bitbucket.
Really straightforward stuff.
And we will fix up the labels
on these pages,
which are back to front.
Now, there is also a part of
RTCPeerConnection, which is
RTCDataChannel.
This is the API for
arbitrary data
communication between peers.
And some examples here.
Let's have a look
at [INAUDIBLE].
This is using the API
for file sharing.
Let's select a file here.
So this is a photograph of a
local pub, and we're using the
RTCDataChannel API
to share this.
Now, if I open this in
a new [INAUDIBLE]
on a new machine, but you can
see that I've actually
downloaded that sharing
peer to peer.
And if I open it up, I should
be able to see--
maybe not.
OK, not with this.
Anyway, I've downloaded
the file here.
This is a great way to
do file sharing.
Let me go back.
I'll just show you another
link there to a
project called PeerCDN.
Now, this is really
interesting.
This is the idea of sharing
content using RTCDataChannel
to enable content distribution
peer to peer.
So it's something
really radical.
We'll see how the future pans
out, but this could be a
completely different way of
sharing content on the
internet, maybe the peer to
peer dream come true.
I would also strongly recommend
you take a look at
the wonderful Cube
Slam game there.
You can play with friends via
WebRTC or with a bear.
So just to keep going, some more
great stuff coming into
media on the web.
We have a JavaScript API
called Encrypted Media.
This is an extension to
HTML Media Elements.
It gives us the ability to deal
with encrypted media on
the web, so simple cases like,
say, maybe corporate
presentations where we're just
sharing a password to more
complex applications where we're
using a plug-in, what's
called content decryption
module, for stuff like Netflix
and so on where we have a
more complex schedule
set up and so on.
So a way for content
distributors to use the web
with encrypted media
extensions.
Now, this has been implemented
using something called Media
Source Extensions.
Media Source Extensions are a
way of chunking out bits of
video, other content
potentially, and then playing
them back using a JavaScript
interface.
Kind of simple [INAUDIBLE]
if you follow the link, kind
of doesn't do much.
But what we're seeing here is
the ability to get chunks of
[INAUDIBLE] and then play them
back using the Media Source
Extensions [INAUDIBLE].
That works, but what makes it
really powerful is the ability
to use this, stuff like what's
called DASH, MPEG-DASH, to do
adaptive streaming.
That means that depending on the
bandwidth conditions and
so on, we can change the actual
quality, the resolution
of the video that's being
downloaded in real time.
So very, very useful in this
modern world where we've got--
I heard that Cisco is estimating
something like 80%
to 90% of web traffic
will be video within
the next three years.
YouTube, we've already got
something like 100 hours of
video uploaded each minute,
six billion views a
month, and so on.
And in that context, stuff like
adaptive streaming with
MSE is going to be really,
really important.
But also, the use of
really good codecs.
Google is working on a codec
called VP9, which is source
and royalty free video
standards.
As we look at the [INAUDIBLE]
here, this is showing VP9 in
comparison with H.264, and you
can see it's comparing very
favorably there with the
existing technology.
[INAUDIBLE]
There's nothing we can compare
with [INAUDIBLE].
Let's go out of full screen.
IDO GREEN: So maybe you could
repeat the last sentence,
because I think we couldn't
hear it well.
SAM DUTTON: Sorry, yeah.
So the demo there, people might
think that's an unfair
comparison because it's not
comparing with H.265, the next
version following on from H.264,
also known as HEVC,
confusingly.
We don't have a playback
mechanism for that, that can
compare with in that way.
But really to show that VP9 is
comparing very favorably,
certainly with existing encoding
technology there.
And there's a stack of several
more links if you'd like to
find out more about VP9.
You know, think about coping is
this coming world where we
have HD on the rise, we have
broadcasters moving to IPTV,
in other words, broadcast
over the internet.
And I saw some figures the other
day for the BBC here in
the UK, TV viewing,
broadcasting, is still pretty
much all-- it's like all
still on televisions.
It's something like 1%, I think,
2% maybe of people here
are watching TV on
the internet.
So there's a huge opportunity
there.
There's going to be a huge shift
in the way people view
TV, so we really--
IDO GREEN: Absolutely,
absolutely.
I agree.
And I think there was a very
interesting blog post that
showed the stats of Netflix
in the US--
and obviously, it will go to
other markets as well--
the numbers there are
just staggering.
Like you said, basically, on
what we have today in YouTube.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's right.
We've got this huge
move from--
well, it's video viewing
onto the internet.
I think I saw some figures from
the US that people are
now spending more time on the
internet, and a lot of that
watching video.
And that's going to require
these really good
technologies, like MSE and great
codecs like VP9, for the
internet to keep going.
So some great stuff there,
and check out the links.
There's a whole stack of
more material there.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
And maybe we'll just
go for the last--
oh, by the way, I wanted to ask
you about the encrypted
media because I've got questions
from start-ups that
wanted to try and start
playing, or let's say,
developing and check
this technology.
Where does it stand today in
terms of enabling us to
encrypt, decrypt on the client,
and what can you share
with us in terms of where
this project is going?
SAM DUTTON: So over the next
couple of months, we're going
to actually be producing
something called "EME in a
Box." So this is going to be
a complete starter pack for
people who want to have
a go with EME.
In the meantime, I would
check out the links
that we've got there.
Actually, I can share some more
stuff later, some more
resources about how EME works
and how you might implement it
in your project.
But we will be producing some
more materials, resources, for
developers so that they can
integrate the encryption part,
key servers, and the actual
web applications, in their
infrastructure.
IDO GREEN: Excellent.
SAM DUTTON: Their app.
So--
SAM DUTTON: We'll
keep you posted.
We'll distribute that stuff.
It will be available in
the next month or two.
IDO GREEN: Great.
And then last but not
least, we put
some links to resources.
So of course, we'll have the
recording, so people that
weren't with us.
And I know there are a few that
would love to see the
recording, so of course we'll
have a link there.
And there's a Google I/O
presentation on WebRTC.
I highly recommend it.
I watched it live and then
watched it again three or four
weeks ago, and it's a
great presentation.
And then we have two tutorials
on HTML5 Rock about WebRTC
basics and an eBook
or paperback
that you could purchase.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
that's right.
The book is brilliant.
I really like that.
Download it to your eBook
reader, and it's just coming
out in the second edition.
We'll actually put a
link there, too.
The other resource I
would recommend--
shameless self-promotion--
is the Codelab that we did at
Google I/O. That shows you how
to make a complete video
chat application,
including how to build--
really, really simple--
how to build a signaling server
using Node JS and
Socket I/O.
IDO GREEN: Excellent,
excellent.
That sounds brilliant.
And then we put a link just to
show where, for developers
that want to see what are their
users using, and then
plan ahead and see.
So as you mentioned, it's
supported today in Firefox and
Chrome, and hopefully Opera
will join the gang soon.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] happens elsewhere.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So that's pretty cool.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
That's great.
You also might want to check
out chromestatus.com.
We'll put a link to that, too.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
SAM DUTTON: This tells you the
implementation status of APIs
in Chrome and Chromium.
Great resource.
Just been relaunched.
That's another good way to find
out when things are on
the way, how standardization
is going, and so on.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, absolutely.
[INAUDIBLE] .com/features.
I really like the new edition
to see exactly which API is
going to be supported in which
platforms, and some great work
over there.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, beautiful
piece of work.
That's very nice.
IDO GREEN: Excellent.
Excellent.
So I think we are
just on time.
I would like to thank you very
much for joining us and
putting some lights on this
cool, new technology.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks, everyone
there, for joining us, and
apologies for the confusion
of RTCDataChannel and
PeerConnection.
We'll put some more
links up there.
I hope it's useful.
If you're working on
stuff, please feel
free to contact us.
And any bugs with the APIs, we
really appreciate all the bug
reports we've had, and feature
requests, and all that stuff.
crbug.com/new.
That's the place for your
comments on the WebRTC APIs.
So thank you.
IDO GREEN: Yeah, absolutely.
So thank you very much, and
until next time, be strong.
Bye bye.
SAM DUTTON: See you.